tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessimo video
sono qua vj di soldati su due mesi fa
erano rimasti ragazzi l'ho scoperto i
test le teste rooms che sarebbero queste
stanze dove posso fare degli esperimenti
jump to join perfetto studi ex di maiali
dance
io non l'ho mai visto nulla di così figo
credetemi io vorrei capire il dato
seduto xhafaj questa stampa c'è ragazzi
ok è una carta sono morto bello è stato
ben ragazzi finisco qui il video io mi
ricordo ragazzi più come ci si muove
però questo striscia e basta con dopare
bene vorrei provare a fare un po di
critico
scusami tanto se c'è chi ce lo fa bene
sono passi avanti e per per niente sono
morto di nuovo bravo che è bello ragazzi
che vengono mai via ecco hai trovato il
tuo habitat zio l'albero va bene
facciamo un cambio di di roba be on
development office
ok sono già che sono una rana è meglio
ho fatto un casino preciso delle armi a
terra poi si prendono armi che non mi
ricordo più l'unico eccolo già sparando
legata io lo so che hai paura di
impugnarlo so non tremare però mi fai
l'occhiolino e ha paura di usare
quest'arma quindi sta tremando è normale
la prima volta proprio calmo calmo che
se noti parte di colpi è svenuto per la
tensione o ci sei a posto ecco bravo
bravo fatevi dare l'allarme ieri in base
alla madonna
fatemi capire cos'è calmi
cosa è successo salve buon già è morto
va beh cosa fai mi sento intanto lo
stupro cosa fa e cosa fa no no cosa kart
madonna di quello ti ammazzo di botte
riano e uno stupro di massa è una cosa
fate
ma [ __ ] no vabbè dai nonni che
cazzo succede quando papà che fanno nome
fatti ecco la scorreggia no ai cani che
cosa mio dio santo se vi fate liberare
da questo schifo io se fossi stato goku
li avrei mandati a [ __ ] tutti subito
no no non mi avrete non mi avrete
com vai vai mai mai mai mai mai mai mai
si no bastardi ragazzi corri corri salta
perfetto voi mi dovete spiegare perché
perché non cazzo ci sono dei fottuti
four c che singola cosa state facendo
voi porci sapete contro quel maiale
stronze già cos'è c'è un barile dietro
indietro bastardi
ecco io l'ho detto che al giorno ragazzi
direi che possiamo tornare al nostro
bello caro e vecchio frog di sempre
ho perso una gamba non a latina quello a
parte il fatto che la fanno non giocato
l'ultima volta è vero effettivamente
questa sembra la camper di heisenberg
demo avanti lo stesso perché non importa
sono morto perché c'è una chiave sul
muro out of order
oh mio dio cos'è sta roba dai cani che
non riesco ad entrare e poi un po
difficile entrarci niente io non riesco
non riuscirà set
no sono moro servivo perfetto io vorrei
capire o mio zio guardate che culetto
fantasma passa mente mi sta roba seria
oddio ragazzi narnia allora cos'è ma
posso andarci solo sono chiude non ci
credo non ci posso credere non sa die
veramente sono a narnia sono una rana ok
chi è il genio che ha fatto questa
fortuna che sono morto bello ragazzi
complimenti comunque posso tornare
indietro adesso che
importa che andrebbe un po di shaq solo
io che è successo mi fate il caffè o mio
dio ce n'erano morto a so come una sorta
di cosa
ok me ne vado dai caso grazie di cuore è
bello cos'è ragazzi non voi non avete
idea di che cosa ho visto ragazzi perché
qualcuno c'ha voglia di aiutarmi che c'è
tipo la mano incastrata nel fine
ormai mi sento a casa quando sono qua
perché veramente bene calma calma ecco
sono incastrarmi sento troppo a casa
quando sono entrati unità non lo so
perché chi è quello vado vedere chi
diavolo è perché non vado a vedere una
segreta salve sono famiglie ascolti un
attimo degli elevati salire in macchina
qua come leva tipo ecco bravo
no è tornato in via ascoltami se io ti
offro un passaggio tu sali ok che cazzo
guardi ma zio sei a posto se io ti dico
di guardarmi tu mi guardi va bene ma è
morto dove ragazzi sto tizio e socievole
tanto quanto una rana vado a vedere che
cazzo fa l'altro perché ho sfondato
qualsiasi cosa bene così la parola è
cobas colta zio non mi far incazzare
identificati dimmi chi sei
ci sarà nascosta ride di parlarmi dimmi
chi sei e non ti fanno del male dimmi
chi sei
merda ok perfetto un parcheggio
c'è un [ __ ] perché bello ragazzi più
per è il più bel parcheggio che io abbia
mai visto la morte non entrare la morte
qua dentro
siamo sicuri che veramente vorrei che
cazzo è ancora questo non c'era però
chiusa o mio dio ragazzi c'è un tizio la
giornata adesso vado a centrale
trampolino e poi vado a fare il culo a
quel tizio che non ho capito chi era ora
che lo guarda che giochi centro ma che
centro della madonna
guardali guardali non l'ho preso e vabbè
ci ho provato
c'è un porco ancora alta gente ma è uno
zombie ma basta sibilava affanculo
dovete morire tutti anche tu porco degli
morì alla vieni qua niente non c'è verso
libertà deve uscire di qui mescola addio
ragazzi che al mito fatta una macchina
alla vita adesso adesso fascicoli
insomma no
cosa ma come fa un trampolino a lanciare
una macchina va bene facciamo ci capiamo
fatta ce l'ha fatta se dove lo sci dove
è uscita di preciso no no no non sbaglia
ma mi seguono anche con la macchina
fuori dai [ __ ] prossima donna ho
vinto io mi sa cosa ok ok ragazzi ci
siamo uscita grazie mezz'ora per uscire
e raccoglie le tartarughe ninja questo
comunque lo sapevo
ho lasciato l'arma beva fan qui se ne
frega bava mio è stato tragico tragico
ma io non ne posso più c'è gente c'è
gente ho preso un palo quadri alla
sicurezza visto che non è un infido più
vado con la macchia giorno scorsi per lo
sportello attaccati al portiere
attaccati ai attaccati arca se cazzo
nona liberamente ma che figata
no mar mer da cielo quasi fatto un po di
casino ma se la farò un salto epico
ragazzi col busto vera figata
l'adrenalina a mille e stato un salto
della madonna ragazzi che faccio se
sopra l'autobus la picchia sopra la che
cosa epica che cosa fottutamente epica
ok che figata epica e questa ragazzi ma
posso fare tipo nba professional proprio
mara che roba guarda che roba
incredibile terzo tempo cioè c'è pure un
canovi stoffa il mio dio
sì sì ragazzi oggi credo non ci posso
credere solo quasi ci riprovo ragazzi
perché è triste che non sia riuscito ma
che chiamare di fisica cia sto gioco che
non ho capi guarda che roba guarda che
roba se stavolta sono rimasto incastrato
nel canestro ma si può mai porca [ __ ]
sul serio ma sul set ti puoi girare
verso si no voi fate finta che io
l'abbia fatto che ai trust auto la
prendo
stavolta lo piglio minchia peggio di
prima ma [ __ ] ma non ci crede
non lo dico il processo successo
bello bellissimo complimento penso che
così che io scendo per strada nel
prossimo episodio cerco di capire come
cazzo diverso è difficile che non è
possibile datemi una mano ragazze
qualcosa perché ammazzarmi per capire
comunque lo farò cosa fai se stai
facendo sì perché gli di lanciarvi
contributi
questo è diventato il cuore la roma
vuole arrampicarti non lo so vallivero
prima con chi ragazzi concluso il filo
episodio se il video è piaciuto consente
a 100 momento mi piace fatemi sapere se
a verifica di come sarebbe su quel cazzo
di cose perché io al massimo cappotto
dalle macchine ma non ci riesco ci ho
provato
quindi ragazzi servito il più autorevole
che figo che si appoggia a me sei un
genio 0 bisogna piuttosto perché mi
piace anche a pacciani facebook e come
lo trattano le iscrizioni sono risentiti
iphone ci vediamo al prossimo video
della ragazza
[Musica]